what film are you most proud of is it
milk yeah I don't know if I've ever
thought that through
certainly that movie you know that gets
Gus Van Zandt almost everything he
touches he touches for its own sake in
the sense that he gives himself to the
style that the story dictates he's got
you know that rarest him and quality of
humility and and yet incredible talent
so as much as any movie I've ever been
involved in milk when you played Harvey
Milk you were running tapes of this guy
right constantly in your trailer or
whatever the hell you were here was a
guy who notwithstanding the gay rights
that he was a heroic symbol of and
leader and just this person as a man
watching him and there's a lot of
archival footage of it you feel such a
love and affection I increasingly as I
was moving towards making that movie
just felt this sorrow that I would never
have never get it to meet him was
somebody wanted to know got a person
that touched you in life and the people
that had known him were so affected by
him and so it's kind of like a song that
touches you you deeply you know a lot of
actors will play music on a set you know
to get themselves in a place I didn't
have to do that when it came to onset
because you know he had become the song
in my life at that time where I would
playing music because I had cued up
because I would come over to visit
Darrell in San Francisco as I come down
towards the Castro district where we
shot a lot of the movie and I just like
my buddy Chet and I as he was he's my
driver on movies and he's like this this
tough bill fireplug New Yorker and he
knew that as we're about to summit the
hill and I see the Castro below on our
way to work he'd hit the CD and we'd be
blasting it's raining men I get you into
it huh yeah I was right there I was
going
I was going to dance with the fellas you
bet